CBS News elections and surveys director
Anthony salvato is here Anthony good
morning so we've had weeks of partisan
argument over impeachment we've had lots
of testimony booklets of testimony yes
where does that leave things still with
partisan splits yeah it really hasn't
moved a lot that number you cited about
deserves not deserves impeachment and
one of the reasons is that people tell
us they don't think the Democrats have
made their case very clearly they don't
necessarily think the Republicans have
either mind you but even people who said
coming into this their mind wasn't made
up haven't all moved in one direction or
another so what are they saying about
the next step in the impeachment process
so next steps more splits you've got 42
percent who say that they'd like to see
the president removed but just as many
equally as many say either not to
convict or don't hold a trial at all and
one thing to point out is that those
numbers on removal are always a little
bit smaller than support for the
impeachment process because not
everybody thinks that even if it's
impeachable it deserves removing only
seven twenty seven percent of people
think Democrats made their case clearly
only 21 percent of people think
Republicans made their case clearly so
basically the majority of Americans
don't know what's going on they don't
think it's been done well on the
campaign trail they're not talking about
it voters aren't asking about it are
they
no in fact Democrats say they'd rather
have their candidates talking about how
to beat Donald Trump than impeach and
remove him interesting in the CBS News
battleground tracker poll the new one
that among the five candidates there's a
surprising newcomer here in yeah that
Mike Bloomberg yes he's in fifth place
now he's not near that top tier that Joe
Biden Elizabeth wore and Bernie Sanders
yet but he's just gotten started and
these are in the Super Tuesday states
that's where he's trying to play quite
an accomplishment though Anthony's
considering that he just got in that
he's even in the top five yes for
context it is and you know what we see
is that he draws a little bit of support
from former Joe Biden supporters and a
little bit from people who think that
party is moving in a too liberal
direction
now his hurdle of course is that that's
not most Democrats most Democrats are
saying the party is ideologically okay
but that could be his his entry how are
Democrats feeling about the diversity of
their field which began very diverse
it's gotten less so right so you know
this is a lot about what people think
other people will think in the sense of
right yeah in the sense of Democrats are
trying to pick a nominee that they think
can beat Donald Trump well how do you do
that a lot of Democrats feel that if
they nominate a woman or if they
nominate someone of color that will
actually make their chances harder again
this isn't what they want is what they
think swing voters will want which kind
of tells you about how people look
across so how how are they feeling about
the primary race so far in general
nervous yeah nervous you know there
there's only somewhat confident that
they can pick somebody who can beat
Donald Trump and they're more nervous
than they are optimistic now political
campaigns can be concerned it can be
uncertain but they also tell you well
they see a lot of infighting between the
candidates and that's not helped I think
it's interesting what you said they're
trying to they're trying to think what
other people are thinking as they make
their decision how do you deal with that
only 22% of them are excited about their
options it is because most of they
mostly just want a winner right they
want a winner look political consultants
have a hard time doing it you know maybe
the public will do it better than they
will all right you know right Anthony
thank you